so me and oswalu have been quarantined
and we've been fighting a lot lately
it's almost like he's trying to
purposefully expose himself
to get coronavirus aswelu's been going
out with his friends
during the pandemic and lying about it
to kalani
so for the safety of her kids she told
him
he has to go i told him that i think it
would be best if he would just
go to his mom's so now i booked a
one-way ticket for him
i don't know when he's coming back
because this is not working
it's not working anymore a one-way
ticket
i tell you quarantine has been the
ultimate revealer
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
the latest episode of happily ever after
was our last time
seeing the couples before part one of
the season five
tell-all which airs next week i'm going
to update you on where
everyone stands before they come face to
face to discuss
the season's most intense and
shocking moments now we are ready to go
to the airport but please
i need some money
all right before we get into the other
couples let's keep it going with asuelu
and kalani at the top of this week's
episode
they said goodbye to his mom and sister
who were headed back to washington
after their face-to-face sit-down with
kalani's parents
yesterday is a good day for us whatever
was broken my heart is
all fixed drop down but please just what
keep telling me
where is jimmy uh
left this morning tammy is still holding
on tight
to that grudge but at least i swear
lou's mom
loved her son on a good note
i need some money
why are you looking at each other
oh no not my kids just didn't just
kidding
you gave me a heart attack i will not
send any money to you give me a heart
attack
don't make any jokes like that you make
me a heart attack
she had me there for a second even
though i'm glad they can laugh about it
now
i'm with asuelu jokes about that
situation
[Music]
they're off limits for her well little
did asuelu know
he would be seeing his mom again very
soon
three months after they said goodbye
covet 19
hit the u.s and according to kalani
during that time asuelu was operating as
if
he was untouchable he didn't know that i
had a tracker on his phone
i said oh where'd you go and he's like
oh i just went driving
i was like oh did you because i'm pretty
sure you went to volleyball
and then i flipped my phone around i
said well here's where you were and then
his face like
froze and then he says like
i'm really sorry that that happened but
i had to lie because you would have
gotten mad and i said
yeah because we're in quarantine at this
point
i don't really see the point of being
married anymore
those are some strong words it seems as
if kalani is just tired of feeling as if
she has
three kids instead of two well here's
osuelu's take on
all of this i think i understand
how kobe 19 is going around
so i could play volleyball but i was
be careful kalani overreacted
and decided that i should take a break
to go
see my mom and my sister in washington
like i don't want to go away
and that's really hard for me to accept
the next morning
3 a.m to be exact asuelu put his bags in
the car
and headed off to the airport kalani
admitted that
she's sad he's leaving but after
everything they've been going through
she doesn't know if she's gonna miss him
so now
it's like real i'm gonna
take a flight to seattle and i
really miss my my wife and also my kids
i tried to facetime my family but
my wife didn't answer i don't know
how they feel when they wake up without
their dad well hopefully that was a big
eye-opener for asuelu from the looks of
social media it seems as if these two
are still together but of course we
won't officially know
until the tell-all moving on to angela
who lost her mother during this episode
fortunately she made it back to the
states
from nigeria just 10 days before her
mother
passed it was hard
but i stayed strong for
but i think she was really fighting for
us is why she was alive
because i finally told her you know if
you're tired you want to go to daddy go
ahead mama
and she went downhill from there
angela comes off as one of those people
with a tough
shell but a really sensitive heart
and that tough shell is what concerns
her daughter skyla
i feel like mama she's not that open
with
people and she you know she doesn't wear
her sensitive emotions on her sleeve so
i can't really give her the support that
she needs
so i'm just worried about mama angela
got married to michael
and then had to bury her mother in such
a short time span i'm sending
all the love to angela and her family
and i send all the love to any of you
who might have lost a parent as well all
the love and hugs
while angela was mourning her mother
colt was telling his mom miss debbie
that he needs some space
i think you treating me like a man
would be like the best thing that ever
happened to me in terms of relationships
i do treat you like a man what do i what
do i baby you what do i no
i'm just saying like i mean i think you
think i have more power over you than i
do
i don't control your life i never said
you did
look at me like i feel like you're my
mother but we don't have a friendship
and that bothers me i want to get to
know you better i want to know who you
are and
well why don't you find out who you are
first and then you can find out who i am
i'm a bit confused cole gave off a lot
of mixed messaging there
first he said that he wanted his mom to
back off and treat him more like a man
but then he said he wanted to get to
know her more as a friend
honestly i thought they had a great
friendship but
i guess i was wrong just my perspective
i think colt is going to have to start
acting like a man
before he expects his mom to treat him
like one
speaking of cult his ex-wife larissa is
a new
woman on this week's episode larissa
showed off her nose job
and breast augmentation i feel great
about my body and i
really enjoy the new books and the
neonatal
really make a big difference in my life
hey
if you like it larissa i love it alright
well moving on to
tonya and sinjin after contemplating
staying in south africa
with his family shenzhen decided to head
back
to connecticut in an attempt to try to
work
on their relationship i'm happy to be
going home with shenzhen
and i'm happy he's chosen to come home
with me and
get to real work
all right well when it comes to paul and
carini
during last week's episode they headed
back to brazil because
paul has yet to find a job in america
and carini has clearly
not been happy these two have also dealt
with a lot of drama in real time
the couple had an intense argument in
july here in the states
which led to carini filing a restraining
order
against paul ever since then carini has
kept
a low profile on social media but
according to paul's instagram in early
september he was getting ready for a
trip
back to brazil so will karini and paul
appear together during the tell-all
we just have to wait and see alright
last but not least
elizabeth and andre this week's episode
ended with them still partying at the
wedding
and charlie still trying to pick a fight
you're a [ __ ] dude listen
let's throw it away tim okay remember
that right
look dude you are trying to play my
family
to so you can live in america and live
like
nice listen i'm not going to talk about
this stuff anymore
you know promised my wife
but i'm not gonna be bad tonight we're
not gonna be friends tonight
okay we're not gonna be friends maybe
for life we'll figure it out but not
tonight
andre showed up in a really good way
during this episode
now i'm not sure if it's all genuine
but he even apologized to elizabeth's
dad
chuck for how he's treated him maybe i'm
like
sometimes but i know but
i've been wrong okay
i've been rude to you but i want from
now on
all of this to work better in our favor
for the sake of my daughter and your boy
listen
i want us to have a good relationship
going forward
but i'm only half of the equation though
i'm
half of the other half
fair enough fair enough okay cheers
although chuck went along with it he
later revealed that
he still doesn't trust andre there is so
much that is going to be covered during
the three-part
season five tell-all yes i said
three parts it kicks off next sunday
september 27th and concludes
monday october 5th all right 90 day fans
fam
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you